you've booked a hundred rolls in the
last five years if someone were to come
to you and ask you how you did it what
would you tell them what's the Reader's
Digest version never turned down a role
when you're starting because you can't
afford to work work work work work
addition make cold calls build
relationships network promote your work
and I think probably the most important
part of that equation is promoting your
work when you've done something no
matter how small trumpet it because
people in the industry want to know that
you're working you are not desirable if
you're not working and if you're working
and they don't know you're working it's
the same as not working so don't be
afraid to say I just did a fantastic
short and I had a supporting role no you
don't have to say I'm fantastic
I was great in this short instead you
say I'm really happy to have worked with
fill in the blank on what I think was a
very artistic endeavor the DP blah blah
did a fantastic job I'm glad to have
played a small part in the process even
if you were the lead say that then those
people are then going to repost you and
further help promote but I think you
have to promote your work and that's how
you get more work because people say oh
well Kieran's working i want her because
other people want her just like dating
you